welcome to this video and it's Yardbird
again mr. Eric LeBron what do we get
probably a queens in yellow ok so maybe
III I never Bishop g5 I don't know I've
tested many lines against him in this
match we are game 44 here yeah it's a
very high 22 now okay it's not a big
deal but the earlier Queens to at least
make sure 94 is not happening that
quickly this whole setup it's not super
promising for white but it's not not bad
it's um it's just something else against
them against them Queens engine and this
looks a lot like a like a total cova
variation of the Queens gambit so I'm
going to take
that's interesting but k fatigue is it
taking with the night no we see
sacrificing this pawn them probably he
can do that night takes probably bishop
cheeks Quincy seven yeah okay this is
definite compensation so I'm just going
going with a solid move
yeah this is now a very Queens gambit
type of position Talackova Lasker this
kind of thing Black has excellent
chances for equality here probably yes
equalized but then stole things to play
for okay oh I can take with the night
yeah let's do that it's probably okay 23
I guess okay i think the bishop on d5 is
a good piece so i try to trade it night
f5 is probably just a fancy-looking move
that leads nowhere maybe but maybe it
also maybe it's going on okay
k can take this night or move the Queen
yeah something like Queen um I'm going
to yeah they are to g5 was certainly
possible so I'm going to take here they
can take a five with the Queen yep maybe
maybe night to d3 is something that she
can can play for one thing that is a bit
troublesome is that I have somewhat weak
background here have to be have to be
alert that I'm not somehow getting back
rank checkmate it here or something my
queen is a little bit off site mmm yeah
so something like rook see one stair I
don't see her don't see a drawback I can
also take their take on the eight and
then before there may be that one check
I've got rooked III so bottom cautious
rook t3i totally totally overlooked that
move I then rook takes the eight was
really really bad
I wanted to go before now and I looked
III is just totally totally killing me
okay i simply i need to do that I need I
need some some help there with the back
rank okay now i can still play a now
before again Rock d3 is coming that's
sick I was thinking okay here i can
still play before but he won't he won't
check on before he still has rocked III
b3 Queen a two-time warning yeah I have
no other move there roop t3 is killing
me i know but what can i do there's no
other move so quincy one or roxy one
yeah that was bad really really bad I
did I totally were I would I didn't have
any problem there I just shouldn't take
on d aid I wasn't it simply didn't see
that rook to e3 move and this was costly
really really costly
yeah just winch with winds with the
bball maybe not chief or may I don't
know it's probably lost anyway thinking
maybe rope to the seventh somehow I
bishop age five could have been a way to
initiate counter play but it's nothing
serious in any case
night 2 D 3 M aji 34 was also had a
stupid idea but yeah not much you can do
jack not sure this was a sacrifice or
intended but it doesn't really matter
check
anyway okay I only have 13 seconds he
can't blunder the night with 93 but
other than that have very little hope
for anything Bishop to a drug be seven
or something okay Jeff
you can play a for you it's not bad Jeff
okay I can no I'm not really sure why
I'm dragging this on I can resign this
with with five reason with five seconds
yeah I'm not playing well the last
couple of games here really not being
concentrated enough focused enough check
yeah okay I don't think I have any
particular problem me I really don't
think but the problem is that I simply
overlooked the route d3 a resource I was
thinking my rationale is I take take
oops sorry take cake before yes to take
and some nothing is happening it's just
it's just equal this possession nothing
nothing going on but of course after
this he has this move and pull this is
just this is just killing me I mean here
I mean I didn't do anything great yeah
but it still should be quite check right
okay and they have no I'm just I'm just
in a terrible situation you know I have
no moves yeah this rook takes the eight
really was too harmful the only I mean I
only played it because of before being
being the idea other than that is
totally ridiculous to give up the file I
can do something like this for example
and I'm not sure that something happens
here that this of any any problem again
I don't know Queen Queen goes somewhere
and play and I can play before here
maybe this is also a different different
thing yeah this is it should be equal I
don't think I definitely don't have
anything here but it's still as equal
Luke takes the eight is just a really
bad mistake based on this idea that i
can go before yeah h3 is not doing much
but I really have
move them and before him I'm losing
losing stuff here and whenever I'm
losing a pawn that is really bad because
it also makes the night being a very
stable on c5 so it was giving away upon
and hurting me from a strategic point of
view so it it was a bad in what it more
than one way yeah okay thanks for
watching guys bye